passing on his post as first secretary
of the all-powerful communist party
to 60-year-old president miguel
diaz-canel
an image that is supposed to signal the
end of the castro era
although
[Applause]
and because cuba needs him will be
consulted on the most important
strategic
decisions for the destiny of the nation
while billboards hailed the communist
party as the soul of the revolution
its eighth congress transpired behind
closed doors
cubans waited to hear if a much promised
generational change
would finally take place
we expect positive changes because the
younger generation is more modern in
accordance with our
times and open to changes that we need
especially in the economy
but when the names of the new politburo
were finally announced down state media
four of the 14 members were 77 years old
and the rest between 50 and 60. fidel
castro was 33 and raul 29
when they took power more than six
decades ago
like raul castro diaz canel will also
hold the position of president of cuba
at a challenging time the economy is
collapsing
and descent increasing opponent
rosa maria paya says the communist party
won't change crisis the most powerful
cuban families are
struggling in a humanitarian
scale crisis and the answer of the
regime have been more repression
more violence in their case to have the
slightest
opening means for them
to put their actual power at risk and
that is something that they don't want
to do
cuba's communist party is one of only
four in the world that remains in power
and describes its future as one of
continuity
guaranteeing that continuity with a more
emboldened younger generation of cubans
may no longer be so easy lucian human
al jazeera